[Music]
hey there guys thanks for tuning in
so doing something a bit different today
recently the channel
crossed 400 000 subscribers which is
really awesome and feels like a
milestone
just want to say a massive thank you to
all of you for subscribing
and for commenting and supporting the
channel honestly you don't know how much
it means to me i didn't do anything to
mark the occasion when we reached 300
000 subs so i thought it'd be good to do
something now make a little
special video also i'm working on
something really big i thought this
would be a fun way to
tie this over until then i am of course
talking about a q a i asked you guys to
shoot me any questions that you had
and i do my best to answer them here so
without further ado let's get on to the
questions
and the first question i have here is
from sean delaney
who asks do you practice intermittent
fasting and if so
what have you found to be the best
timing for it this is something i'm
actually talking about
in that upcoming video but suffice to
say yes i do like intermittent fasting
on paper i think it offers a huge number
of benefits
i'm more interested in stuff like
autophagy and
nad plus production rather than
necessarily just
losing weight and reducing calories
although this is obviously a big benefit
too
so with that in mind i think if you're
fasting you should aim to be fasting for
at least 16 hours
because that's when the most autophagy
kicks in autophagy is not a binary it's
more of a spectrum you always have some
autophagy going on in the body
but to get the most benefit you want to
go to that 16 hour point
that's why i ideally when i'm trying to
do it will go to 18 hours but it also
depends on
my routine and stuff i like to eat with
my family and my kids i don't
necessarily have to do intermittent
fasting every day or every week
you can intermittently intermittently
fast right so the next one is from sj
at chaos untold and she says i know that
your main audience is men but would you
consider doing any
women superhero training guides for us
women fans of the channel
it's nice to know you guys are out there
and this is something that i wanted to
address because yeah i really do want to
do
some uh female superhero training guides
the only reason i haven't is because
it's actually quite hard picking
superheroes to focus on for these videos
because
if they have too many powers something
like superman i mean what i'm gonna talk
about because you can't train
to shoot lasers out of your eyes as far
as i'm aware if ever i figure it out
i'll be sure to
share that one and if i do people
without any powers they basically all
just become
batman so yeah something like the flash
is a really good way to talk about
speed in particular and so that's lent
itself well but yeah i'm trying to just
find a good angle
for a female superhero to cover that
just offer something different i haven't
covered before because the main thing
is that none of these videos are
intended just for men they might
feature male superheroes but the point
is that the same training advice on the
whole applies to everyone they're very
limited small differences in terms of
how you might apply that for women so
yeah on the whole anything i've made is
for everybody and yes i
am hoping to do a female superhero
training program soon with all my ideas
i have these ideas but i need to find a
hook and angle
that i think really excites me about
that topic before i can tackle it i've
got a longer question here from
justin andrew moore and he says what
were the biggest challenges you faced
when it came to continuing to work and
to train as a new father
and what tools and strategies did you
use to stay on track and continue to
develop and perform at a high level
despite the unpredictability of schedule
and increase in responsibility
asking for a friend laughing face and
i've actually had quite a few
questions like this one so it's a good
one to tackle now
and yeah it's true having a kid really
does change everything you're exhausted
all the time
and working from home as i did even
before
locked down because you know i've always
been self-employed does in some ways
make that even more challenging
and uh yeah lately i've been taking on
even more responsibilities
uh looking after me full-time as i'll
explain a bit more in the next video so
yeah managing to work around that is
pretty tough going but for me obviously
the fact that my job allows me to train
does help a little bit because i have an
excuse to go outside and train but the
other big thing is what i talked about
in
many previous videos and that's just
splitting my training up throughout the
day this is something that i was
interested in as a hypothetical but it
has become my de facto way of training
and the other big thing that i'd say has
been difficult as a parent is injury and
recovery because
you know when i'm training hard having a
a little one doesn't really give you
tons of time to recover
normally if i'd tweaked my back say then
i might say okay i won't do
any um cleans or deadlifts for a while
i'll let my back recover but
unfortunately if you've got a uh
i don't know how heavy she is seven
kilograms maybe but wriggly
and unaccommodating resistance if you've
got a little one who's that heavy and
she's in the
cot and you've got to bend over to pick
her up because it's five o'clock in the
morning and your back's still sore
then yeah you're just exposing it to so
many opportunities for injury
you know a lot of people say as they get
older and they age they become more
prone to injury
find it harder to train but i actually
think lifestyle is such a big part of
that
because if you're a parent yeah you're
just working so much harder getting so
much less sleep and it's cumulative
over time so it's kind of allowed me to
you know put myself in the shoes of some
of the people that i've trained or given
advice to in the past
who um perhaps you know are struggling
with these kinds of ailments so actually
it's been useful in that sense and it's
it's showed me that it there's benefit
to me training carefully
and making sure i strengthen my back and
things like that so actually in that
sense it's been a learning curve
and you have to see training not only as
something that you do
to exert yourself and to break yourself
down but training can also be what you
do to fortify yourself it can be
comfortable sometimes i put on relaxing
music
do some mobility or hold some static
poses that strengthen some weak areas
and it's actually you know it's a it's a
decompression
and that's just as important as going
hard all the time
so yeah that's something else i've
learned that's how i've coped with that
social toby says in the last months your
videos
and your book super functional training
changed my philosophy about strength
training and i love your batman workout
thank you very much
as a martial artist tell us something
about your martial arts journey
i think you're a black belt in karate
what style how long
you did it where and what have you been
training for martial arts
and how has your martial arts training
benefited or influenced your functional
training
uh that's a really interesting question
um i don't consider myself to be
you know a martial artist per se or a
particularly good one but i am
fascinated in martial arts and i do
practice them
to a degree and for a time i just loved
martial arts
jackie chan and shenmue were two of the
biggest influences for me growing up
and they not only got me into martial
arts but also fitness training along
with my
um step grandfather bernard hunt who i
met
when i was 10 11 12 i don't know but he
started teaching me some basic
self-defense that he learned from the
army
and also showed me some functional
exercises he didn't call them that but i
was doing things like
sit-ups with my um arms behind a broom
so that i
couldn't cheat and use momentum and had
to use just my core strength and he
got me doing things like catching coins
off my uh forearm he was kind of like
mr miyagi to my daniel um and as a kid
who um
had lost his father recently when i was
nine actually which is probably one of
the reasons for my big um
you know superhero obsession male role
model thing
um as a result of that i just took to
this
you know really well and just loved it
so i was started training every single
night
um and also looked into martial arts for
ages
i was resistant to doing martial arts in
a traditional sense because
i didn't really like clubs i wasn't
really social you know i liked hanging
out with friends and things but
i'm not really a club or you know
joining kind of person
but eventually i took wadaroo karate and
i did really enjoy that made lots of
good friends there
trained in that for five years and what
are we karate for those that don't know
is a slightly softer style of karate
which has got a lot of um
influences from things like wing chun
you do
a lot of trapping and arm bars and
things like that on top of the regular
punching
um and i did competitions and i won a
trophy
and for a while that was a huge aspect
of my life
i also then did capoeira and tai chi um
at the same time
in the latter years i did tai chi for
about a year with um
bernard my grandad and i did capoeira as
well with a friend from karate
which i took to obviously because i did
all the hand balancing and stuff so yeah
for that for that time martial arts was
a big part of my life and
probably the exercise was almost
secondary to that then i went to
university
and i had to stop doing the karate
because you know it was in a different
area and i couldn't find water anywhere
at the time i was really
set on progressing with that and not
starting something new or fresh which is
definitely what i would do now
um you know i would have liked to have
done something like jiu-jitsu
however back then i just wanted to carry
on with my karate
which i didn't have the option to do so
i didn't do anything basically
instead i got into rock climbing and
just did more of the gym
and actually that's where i learned that
my real passion was fitness because
more so than fighting like jackie chan i
wanted to move like jackie chan
and at the same time i found that
fitness fed into all the different
skills like rock climbing like hand
balancing like martial arts
and that's what really set me down this
path so yeah martial arts did have a big
impact on that but for five years i
barely practiced martial arts i just
used a heavy bag
for cardio and for strength endurance
and
conditioning but then later on i got
more interested in
it again and uh met grant as well
and grant was really inspiring to me
because he told me that he
learned most of his incredible
techniques himself self-taught watching
videos playing them back
repeating the movements so i realized if
he can get that good then
theoretically i could as well so when
i've met him he's been giving me
pointers and i've been practicing a
little bit more
on the heavy bag i hope i've improved
slightly um you guys
often comment that i just literally do
jabs and crosses and that's just because
i'm trying to get my crosses
better so i'm just drilling those at the
moment
but yeah that's where i am right now and
my lifestyle at the moment doesn't
really permit me to go to a regular
martial arts class
so this is working for me but i'd like
to do that again in the future and
i'm also hoping to get more critique
from grant i might do some online
courses so yeah
i'm now realizing that just as i've kind
of pursued my own fitness journey i can
do the same thing with martial arts
so we'll see where it goes from here hey
guys this is adam from one day in the
future
this just arrived in the post just in
time a little bit of a celebration
i've created some new merch i've got
t-shirts hoodies
joggers leggings tank tops for men and
for women in all sizes
that's a super functional on them and
super functional training
on the back just as a little way to you
know mark the occasion and if
you like the concept of super functional
training if it's something that
resonates with you then this is a way
that you can
demonstrate that and wear it to the gym
these tops are from
teespring they're actually very
comfortable and well fitted i don't
think
too ridiculous though and you can find
them in the little carousel thing
at the bottom underneath any of these
videos or alternatively you can go to
the shop page on the bioneer and find
them there alongside some other stuff
including a new canvas print which some
people are interested in
and of course you can still also get the
bioneer logo t-shirts and tank tops
now available in black also by popular
demand thanks so much to all you guys
who bought one of those
and for sharing them on instagram really
appreciate it
and it's it's very cool to see people
liking the logo
a question from scottish herbivore is oh
another question if it's not too late
it's not too late what's the best way to
train manual dexterity
or fine motor skills and there are
actually plenty of options
great question by the way because this
is such an overlooked aspect of
performance it's great for the brain
and it's um you know something that you
actually use a lot in various types of
activity
and i'm definitely going to make a video
on this again i have made a smaller
video on this
in the past and there i described
cursive as one of the best things you
can do to improve your dexterity
and especially writing with your
non-dominant hand which for me would be
my left hand
otherwise piano on an instrument can be
really good you know a lot of people
think we don't practice that much
movement that much complex movement
these days in our modern lifestyles but
manual dexterity is another matter a lot
of us are still doing that and that's
great the chaired on
at bazwish on twitter is a chair
um at least according to their profile
picture on twitter and they say
am i a fitting chair to do bench dips on
and i would say
yes because you can do bench dips on
really any raised surface i think that's
the question that everyone wanted the
answer to
the most
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
rob rod leader says is your physique the
result of strength training
bodybuilding functional fitness a blend
of it all i'm curious about your fitness
journey
so as i told you guys i started off
doing martial arts
and also um some kind of functional
training that my
granddad had taught me but from there i
then also joined the gym
with my buddy goof and uh got more into
kind of like bodybuilding on the side
and then
that became more what i did and i wasn't
specifically interested in bodybuilding
it was just the a
back then the most information was
telling you how to do bodybuilding and
also arnie was a big hero of mine and
stallone in particular actually
at the same time i just really responded
to it i like the way it feels the pump
and yeah i seem to be quite good at it i
had a big bench press
and could easily get bigger arms and
things and also i love the reaction of
people to be honest you know
go into going to school when you're 14
and having
a bicep peak that um you're known for
just became a part of my identity
and because i took to it quickly you
know people like things that they
naturally
take to quite well it was later on that
i started to do more functional training
because i realized that i'm always i've
always been more interested in
performance than aesthetics
i just didn't really understand the
difference when i started out
but in terms of which impacted on my uh
physique the most i'd say it's actually
a combination of both
i think one of the reasons that i'm able
to maintain
fairly strong looking physique without
even though i'm sometimes going for
stints where i'm not able to train as
much as i'd like is because i did a lot
of pump training really high volume pump
training with heavy weights when i was
younger
which i've later learned would have
increased my my nuclei count
um it would have improved blood flow to
the muscles and you know so muscle
memory kicks in
and it means that i can gain muscle back
even more easily because i was once
big but also big in this specific kind
of way if that makes any sense and i
think this also feeds into the
effectiveness
of creatine for me i find that my body
has a really beneficial reaction to
creatine in terms of
gaining size so but then on top of that
uh functional training and i'm gonna do
a video on this soon uh is actually
great for aesthetics this is what a lot
of people don't realize because when i
was doing
that i didn't really know what i was
doing when i was doing the bodybuilding
i was ignoring certain body parts i was
completely imbalanced
whereas now i'm obviously training in
more planes of motion i'm trying to
balance out my physique more and
actually perform better
and what this does is it fills in the
gaps so you know things like my serratus
and obliques
look far better since i've been doing
things like medicine ball slams and
rope climbing etc and my forearms look
better so before i had this kind of like
puffy
look where muscles were big but they're
like on this thin frame where since
doing the functional training
i've kind of maintained that um on a
hole but i've also kind of
added detail in these other areas so in
that sense um
you know in terms of physique and
appearance it is a combination
of the two which is why i actually
generally tell people to
perform functional training but also not
to throw the baby out with the bath
water
and say bodybuilding sucks because it
doesn't and it is functional in terms of
building
um you know symmetry if you focus on the
right muscles and balance
because the whole point is that you're
bringing up things to meet the standards
of the rest of your body
and at the same time it builds strength
endurance which is functional so
yeah combine them both i think is a
great approach and i just stumbled upon
that approach
ricky cutter says what was your worst
injury and how did it happen
and the answer is that i broke my wrist
extremely severely
when i was doing my gcses
so i would have been about 15 or 16
and what happened there is my friend and
i went to
a karate class um in a hall it was
located somewhere different because they
had like they're speaking to a guest or
something so we went along to this event
in the hall and then it finished and
instead of going home my friend and i
thought it'd be funny to
break into another empty hall i didn't
break in the doors open there was no
vandalism involved but you know we were
naughty kids
rascals and this empty hall had these
big foam blocks
in it you know like the kids used to
jump around on and what we did was we
built a tower of them
where i would stand on one and then he'd
throw me one and i put it underneath
myself and then he threw me another one
and i'd step on that one
thus building the tower higher and
higher and i was going higher and higher
at the same time because
you know i thought this was a great
jackie chan esque stunt and they threw
me one
at the when i was really high up i was
high enough to reach the ceiling fan
and it knocked me in the tower my theory
was that if i fell i'd land on the soft
things so i wouldn't hurt myself but
what actually happened is i kicked the
soft pile of things out that way and i
went straight down
landed on my wrist and elbow and head
and
yeah from quite great height onto hard
wooden floor and when i
opened my eyes i tried to push myself up
and i found i couldn't
that's odd and i looked at my hand and
it was literally on almost
backwards it was um you know both the
brains were broken the growth plate was
smashed
and my hand was around like that and the
skin was all bunched up
and so the obvious thing i thought is i
can't tell my mum because she'll be mad
also we had a
holiday to america booked which was a
big
exciting event for us which i didn't
want to be cancelled so i said to my
friend
what you got to do is pull my hand
because it's clearly dislocated
and it'll click back into place which is
impossible you can't dissipate your
wrist
i didn't know this uh he pulled it did
not make me better in fact apparently i
was very lucky not to lose
movement in my hand by destroying my
nerves um and so yes i
uh i went to the hospital and i was in
cast for
collectively multiple months um
and it actually broke again didn't break
it moved inside not to have a
pin in it and it's caused me aggro ever
since
and it's a bit of a pain because i
currently have some
elbow pain and i think you know i've had
it and gotten rid of it and hadn't got
rid of it and it's because my wrist
you know lacks mobility compared to the
other one and uh just generally this is
a weak point for me my whole right side
is my
weak point as a result which you know
sucks i also have broke my ankle
um by sticking a rabbit hole so it's
literally my right side
and all these injuries kind of coalesce
and spread through the body but it's
just
part of the challenge is overcoming and
working around that and my friend joked
because um
he said a lot of people at hospital say
things like will i ever walk again and i
said will i ever walk on my hands again
um which he found amusing and they
actually said i would never walk on my
hands again
and i can walk on my hands and i never
got arthritis when i was 21 which they
said i would
so that's all positive uh the downside
like i say is that it still hurts and
for those that have asked why i wear
this wristband
that's actually the reason although it's
not what you think it's not for push-ups
and things
it's because when i'm typing on the
computer or using the mouse
that's when this wrist gives me aggro so
i wear this
for work and i just find myself keeping
it on and it's actually got all these
other uses
you can use it as a mild form of blood
flow restriction training
i use it to clean my camera and i think
it looks
cool in a kind of like retro street
fighter streets of rage
way so that's why i wear the wristbands
so bartel
horch henrichsen says the obvious
question is
which superhero is your favorite and in
a related
question tim hogan says favorite comic
book run or storyline
so my favorite superhero i probably have
a few
it may surprise you to learn that my og
favorite superhero the one that got me
into comics
was iron man long before he was famous
thanks to the mcu back when he was
considered
b-list b-tier iron man was always my
go-to
guy just because i found the character
of tony stark as compelling as iron man
i loved all the technology loved robots
as a kid so he appealed to me on that
level
and yeah i just found him this relatable
interesting character who
did stuff that wasn't just superheroing
that i also wanted to read about
whenever i'd read about spider-man i'd
just be like put your mask back on man
peter parker's boring but with tony
stark it was a bit different
and the comic run that got me into iron
man and so one of my favorites
was by len kaminsky and he's the guy who
introduced war machine
and the modular armor which was really
cool he could add these massive guns to
his arm for specific missions that did
different things
and this was the 90s so of course
everything looked really awesome
all the guns were massive there were
wires hanging out everywhere i just
really liked it
and another comic at that time that i
was reading a lot of was uh
simon furman's transformers generation 2
which i also
loved and of course i really liked
batman um i was always interested in
batman but when i started this channel
and started researching him i got more
and more
interested in the character and just
what he represented um as a character
with no superheroes he managed to get
tate-to-tay with
you know literal gods which is always
appealing and in terms of the best
batman run i think that grant morrison
by far um is my favorite he just writes
batman in a really awesome way
the mythos how cool and unstoppable he
comes across
and you know just how interesting he
focuses on the training and things a lot
more than others
just just really really cool more
recently i also really like anything by
jonathan hickman his run on x-men has
been
really interesting and his avengers time
runs out and secret wars
were really really cool those comics got
really dark and went to some really
philosophical places which is
what i really like to see in my comics
and his fantastic four run was really
cool as well
which i think is you know what most
people associate him with
martin weaver says natty or not winky
face
um which i think is meant in jest but a
few people have asked
if i am nutty or not and hopefully i
think those
that um you know read about this sort of
thing and are interested
would guess that i am nutty because i
mean i don't have that low body fat at
all
it's like 15 or something got love
handles and
if you watch my videos you'll see that
my um size fluctuate i saw some people
mention that on my blog i did
talk about having used something and
it's true
this is ridiculously embarrassing but
when i was 21 or 22
i took a pro hormone not realizing that
was what it was it was
sold over the counter in a gym it was
called oxavar
and i bought it because i thought it was
a testosterone booster because i was
so green at that point that i didn't
know what the difference was um
and i took this for maybe a few weeks
until the pot ran out
and i did notice some strength gains
actually even though a lot of people say
that pro hormones
aren't effective and i don't know if it
might even be now classified as a
steroid
but that was over 10 years ago um and
i don't think it's had any big impact on
my physique today so i would say that
this was a
completely natural physique i hope you
guys agree on that one i don't have any
problem with people who use steroids i
think if that's
the route they want to go down then
that's fine it's definitely interesting
i find it really interesting
but for me personally the health risks
and issues are just too great
the whole lifestyle is too much of a
commitment for it to really be worth it
and i don't think it's really in the
spirit of this channel
or my own goals in particular i want to
push myself to be the best i can be
without relying on anything like that
and also you know if you do
have an adverse reaction or if you do
find that your natural testosterone has
become
low as a result then i mean that's the
opposite of what i'm trying to achieve
and what you've got to remember with
something like this is even if you feel
that you know exactly what you're doing
and
using trt or steroids or whatever it's
completely safe
if you're buying it from an illegitimate
source online then you can never be sure
you might be you might have done all
your research but if this comes to you
and it's
contaminated it's tainted then you're
still gonna get into trouble so
to me it's just not worth it but like i
say each to their own
sean romanoff says hi informative and
inspiring channel
thank you were you always an athlete and
how did you evolve into the bioneer
first of all thank you very much i
wouldn't say i personally consider
myself to be an
athlete that's a very generous
description more just a hobbyist who is
passionate about human performance but
with that said i've always been somewhat
athletic as a kid i was very into
running
and got into county level competitions
for sprinting 100 meters
and hurdles and as i've said before
um i then later on got into martial arts
and
training from home uh thanks to my
grandad bernard
as for how that then evolved into the
bioneer well as i said
my grandad bernard got me interested in
a more kind of functional form of
training
um i started calisthenics around that
same time i just committed myself to
working out
in my bedroom every single night and
that's what i did for just
years and uh yeah the martial arts on
top of that and then when i went to
university
and just prior to university i kind of
started the more bodybuilding style
training
as well on top of that so that's how i
began that's where my interest started
but
i was always really interested in human
performance i don't know where that
interest came from really say other than
my
sort of session with action heroes and
superheroes
but i used to tell kids in uh school and
in sixth form that i always wanted to be
a stuntman but that wasn't actually true
i was saying a stuntman because i
thought that was more realistic than
what i actually wanted to be
so then later on i admitted that i
wanted to be an action hero you know
like jackie chan
but that still wasn't really true
because what i actually wanted to be was
a superhero
but you know when you tell people you
want to be a superhero when you grow up
they say uh
nah but then when i was going to
university i was considering studying
something like
pe or sports science but i wasn't really
interested in sports per se
i was more interested in training and it
wasn't something that really approached
it
in the way that i was interested and
also i wasn't sure if i was going to go
down that route with my career so i
ended up studying at university
was psychology and my reasoning was that
i was really interested in
you know physical performance but i
wanted the cognitive mental performance
to match that obviously this isn't what
i said
in my applications because that's crazy
but i wanted to learn how to optimize
the mind as well as the body and in
retrospect that was a really good choice
because
i talk about psychology loads on this
channel and neuroscience and
it's fascinating to me and it also just
feeds in the two are so connected and of
course this was a science topic so i
learned a lot about
you know biology in general and how to
analyze a study so all that stuff has
been really helpful for me going
forwards
you know running the site and becoming
the bioneer when i left university i
decided to turn
writing into my main job because i was
i'm also passionate about writing
um it's a big hobby of mine and i became
a freelance writer i decided i never
wanted to work for somebody so i became
a freelance writer but yeah
on top of technology my other big area
was health and fitness and i wrote for
lots and lots of health and fitness and
psychology websites
and so my business strategy was to write
large volumes um for a low rate either
write 10 000 or more words a day
and when you spend eight years writing
10 000 words a day on health and fitness
you hopefully learn some stuff so i went
from someone who had this kind of like
hobbyist
interest in fitness alongside you know
my psychology degree
and then i developed that into hopefully
a much more comprehensive
and also strange knowledge of health and
fitness
i continued to do training myself at
this time and i started
training people online and then i
thought i'd better get a training
qualification so i did that
personal training qualification so
hopefully that combination
um gave me further uh knowledge and then
the stuff i did for android authority
they moved me on to doing videos for
them
and so i learned how to make videos
hopefully to a higher degree
and so the videos i was making for my
website for my youtube channel started
to improve in production quality
i changed the name to the bioneer at the
suggestion of
someone on one of the forums um who i'm
ever grateful for because the bioneer
was such a cool name
um and then just slowly slowly i started
to spend more time on the bioneer and
less time
doing the other writing gigs and now
it's my full-time job and i said just do
one or two things here and there on the
side and i'm currently adding to my
qualifications you know trying to get
new ones here and there studying a
couple at the moment and just to
describe what i think the
bioneer is and what i'm trying to offer
here i still consider myself
primarily a writer specifically a
technical writer you know i've written
books on programming on business
and on fitness which is quite a range a
diverse range of different things and
delivering these as kind of video essays
i research these topics heavily
using the knowledge i have for my degree
and from my experience and also
you know from my time as a writer as
opposed to me talking to you
as someone who you know telling you what
to do i'm just trying to convey
information that i've discovered
provided the sources and my theories as
i tie it together and yeah that's what i
think the bioneer really is
slushy apples asked what's your routine
and a lot of people have asked very
similar questions to this one
and unfortunately the the truth of the
matter is that i don't have a
really strict or regular training
program that i follow
partly because as i've explained working
around a little one means i'm training
at all different times and i'm trying to
keep things interesting
researching things for this channel
partly because of making the channel
like
when i go and film i don't have that
much time at the moment so if i'm doing
a video about
say push-ups or functional training or
something then i'll
head out with my camera and i need to
get all the footage for that in one day
so i can edit it
throughout the rest of the week which
means i'm from training for like two to
three hours and filming it
and not only filming it filming it from
all different angles and doing a weird
number of sets and reps because i'm just
trying to do enough that i can get it on
film
or there's some shot i particularly want
to get like me doing a handspring into a
push-up so i try and try and try like
you guys see it once
but i need to get the right angle i need
to make it look clean so i repeat these
movements so i'm
training around that a lot of the time
this has actually been a really say
weird
aspect of my training i do these big
blocks of workouts that are just
exhausting
and then little bits of sporadic
training throughout the week when i'm
not doing that when i'm working on a
video that i can use old footage or when
i'm working on a video that is about the
brain or something
or when i'm just taking a deload week or
whatever i will
focus on training that's it's really
very similar to not to plug my book but
the
training program in super functional
training the last one
basically i use a combination of
different exercises that do multiple
things for the body all at once
you know why do pull-ups when you can
climb a rope and get
grip benefits and core benefits that are
more profound at the same time you know
that's my kind of approach
i do heavy weights and technical
movements at the start i do lighter
weights
simple isolation movements with high
repetitions at the end i do that
both through the workout and within a
single set because i like to use
mechanical drop sets
i use heavy weights so i'm training max
strength and training technique or i use
you know
a complicated technique like a handstand
push-up and then i move on to the much
easier variation like push-ups and just
bang them out for high repetitions so
i'm getting the conditioning benefits as
well
that's basically the cornerstone of my
training but the specifics
change all the time so i think that's
enough questions for now guys i hope you
found
something i talked about here useful or
interesting and it wasn't just me
mumbling about nonsense for ages um if
you did like it let me know
down below and maybe i'll do one of
these again maybe when we hit 500
000 subscribers i'd like to thank you
guys again so much for helping me get to
this point in the first place
you know i uh i it's a dream come true
literally and your support and the
positivity in the comments and in the
group
and on the facebook page and instagram
it's just fantastic i mean
i i couldn't be luckier and i really
genuinely appreciate it
so yeah here's to the next 100 000
and way beyond thanks so much for
watching this one guys and i'll see you
next time
bye for now adios guys
thanks for watching stay tuned for the
next one see you later
thanks for watching goodbye hope your
arms feel better soon
and yeah thanks for watching uh stay
tuned for the next one i guess
bye for now